it hasn't been an easy ride for iraq's
politicians to win over people's hearts
and minds so they are doing everything
they can to secure votes in the upcoming
elections
and as it is the case these days social
media plays a huge part in the campaign
more than 60 percent of iraqis are
online and active on social media
because it's the easiest and the
cheapest way to reach to the people and
especially we can choose
young people
women
and people they can they cannot offer
maybe to have good electricity to watch
tv all the time
but after the 2019 anti-government
demonstrations that saw hundreds of
protesters killed the real challenge is
convincing people to cast their votes so
we are using also social media to
encourage people to go to vote because
this is number one
before we ask them to whom they vote we
should we ask them to go and vote
but there is resistance some social
media influencers are calling for a
boycott of the elections because they
say politicians need to have better
policies to tackle iraq's challenges
[Music]
with hundreds of thousands of followers
is one of them he's using social media
to promote his anti-election stance
the more we criticize the candidates the
more they're going to push back and try
different ways to win i'm therefore very
pessimistic about the outcome and when i
tackle this issue i'm not going to vote
and will call on people to boycott
social media is playing a crucial role
in the race to get votes during this
elections it's an extension of the more
traditional campaign like this where
pictures and posters of the candidates
are put across the city but many iraqis
are angry at the politicians for failing
to provide services and create jobs so
winning them over will likely prove a
difficult task
we asked iraqis in baghdad if social
media has been effective in changing
their minds during this campaign
i don't see any influence for social
media on our decisions our generation is
mature enough to know who's good and
who's bad we saw what happened in the
october 2019 protest and the price we
paid
social media is very effective we can
watch and differentiate between
candidates who deserves and who doesn't
social media is much more important than
tv and newspapers but our problem in
iraq is that our social media is
partisan just as the country it's
divided into parties sects and paths
this adds to the challenges that
independent candidates face in every
election in a country where
politicization and divisions make it
difficult to get their message across
aliasing al jazeera baghdad